criticism
is not consent
[Music]
take two doctor who review roles on and
it's time to talk about the pyramid at
the end of the world
it's funny looking back on it the what
is now generally thought of as
the monk trilogy is pretty harshly
maligned at this point
by most folks who i see it's generally
dismissed
talked about in terms that just like oh
that thing and it's kind of a shame
because extremists is great
and even this one
it's pretty good i would say that this
is very much a two-parter in that
it's it really doesn't feel complete as
a full experience
but it doesn't totally feel like a
single story split into
either this does feel like uh some
degree of resolution the immediate issue
is dealt with but then another problem
it promptly comes up that's going to be
dealt with next episode
now extremists while it does sort of
load the basis for these other two i
consider to be a pretty self-contained
uh viewing experience this one uh a
little less so
it's still pretty good though
the i don't really have all that much to
criticize because as far as
telling the story that it's telling and
setting up what's coming next
it's pretty solid unfortunately when
you're dealing with the two-parter if
one half does a really good job of
setting up what comes next and then the
other half
drops the ball on it yeah
you're not going to get a lot of people
go well the first part was good
right no you just kind of get people
doing what i usually do when i do like
ranked lists and stuff
lumping it all together treating it as
one thing going
but that sort of leans on the resolution
which is lie the land which we're not
talking about today
opening on this concept of a pyramid
that
they can tell is 5 000 years old
but wasn't there yesterday
that's a good strong opening
a mystery that's solid i dig
that there's also a real good
build up of tension with this i think
little touches like having every single
clock in the world become a doomsday
clock
counting down that really does a
wonderful idea of
just expanding the idea of how far this
reaches because normally it's like
you've got one person keeping track of
how much time they've got left now like
literally anyone who has a clock can see
time is running out that's a really neat
idea
i will say that um i remember when i
watched this the first time
i called the entire trajectory of
the disease in the lab
subplot very early on and i'm not
i don't know how much to criticize that
though because i don't think the episode
is really
trying to play it like a big surprise
because i mean
look an alien species shows up and
basically says
we will save you from a disaster while
at the same time showing us
things going on in a lab and not
explaining how the two are connected
it's not
that hard to put two and two together
given
that i feel like they still try and
build tension out of that half of the
story
and it doesn't really hold it up because
at least i felt it's way too easy to see
where it's going
that being said i really like erica
i think erica the scientist is fantastic
and she probably goes on my list of
people who
i would have been really happy to see
his companions i thought she was
a really interesting presence it was a
good performance she had good rapport
with capaldi
yeah i would have liked to see more of
her
um so i i enjoyed her
quite a bit i also like that we're still
dealing with the lingering consequences
of the doctor's blindness and that here
those consequences become
very tangible and very
direct b and honestly
the whole thing that goes on with his
eyes
and his blindness i like the
see on the one hand the consequences are
immediate
you know when he does what he does in
oxygen to save bill because he loses his
eyesight
but we're still watching dominoes
fall because of that which i appreciate
it's not just like one more thing he has
to work around it's
actually what leads him into the
situation that means
he kind of loses at the end of this
that's
that's nice that's nicely plotted that's
nicely worked out
and i it has already established that
while it can come up with like the
layout of the room what's here what's
there
it can't read things he can see the
shape of something but he can't
read the numbers so
erica can tell him all day long what the
combination is he'll never get it
and that is uh that loophole
that weakness that hole in what the
glasses are able to do for his sight
has already been established so it
doesn't feel like it comes out of
nowhere
and i also really like his reaction
especially when
he kind of has to own up to bill
that he's now gonna die because of this
his exact words were i've made a mistake
i have to face that
which seeing that from the doctor at all
is kind of a good thing but especially
coming on the heels of series 9
and what happened with clara and
as much as i have my issues with hell
bent
this feels like a really good character
moment
because he watched
clara and face the raven make a mistake
and have to face the consequences of
that
and then two episodes later he spent
that entire episode
refusing to accept
the consequences that had already
happened
so to see him take this more
mature approach and grant it's not the
exact same thing and the doctor has
always kind of been
more willing to sacrifice himself than
to sacrifice other people like i get
that
but just knowing that the idea of facing
the consequences of
a mistake was something that was the
core of so many problems not just like
writing problems that i didn't like but
like problems for the character
in the last series this really feels
like a nice
evolution possibly even resolution
on that aspect of capaldi's doctor
so i like that quite a bit i love the
whole idea that the monks
can only take over with consent
and while i don't think the eventual
payoff of the specifics of this
actually mean much
doesn't feel as justified as i would
like i do enjoy the
concept of pure consent
because early on all these other people
saying yes
we consent and the monks
know and then killing these people but
fear
is not consent strategy
is not consent and
then with bill
wanting nothing but to save the doctor
love is consent
and granted
that this whole thing is absolutely a
manipulated scenario and the monks
do know what they're doing
um and have arrived here at this moment
in time for the purposes of
manipulating consent i do still just
in general really like the idea
of demanding consent but
it can't just be saying the words you
have to mean it and you have to mean it
for the right reasons
if you're gonna use a term like consent
which
in these days feels like a
term that means a lot more than it used
to
it's nice to see it as a concept treated
with that kind of gravity and that kind
of precision
broadly speaking while i did criticize
the lab thing
a little bit for its predictability i do
like the idea that what's gonna end the
world
isn't the invasion it isn't
the big thing that the doctor can see
coming and stop
or that unit could track or torchwood
could fight
it's just a small little thing it's a
simple mistake
in a lab the world ends because of
one little mistake that nobody
would have had the power to see or to
stop
except the monks see it and they say
they can stop it
so i i like that as a
as a notion it's it's really hard
i think to pull off the idea of someone
who
and have it feel properly resonant that
people who
quote unquote don't matter bring about
the end of the world
when you have a show that feels like it
is always dealing with like the movers
the shakers the history makers of
actual history and these alien planets
and
obviously the doctor himself etc etc etc
to have it boil down to
just a couple of scientists that almost
nobody even knows that they're working
in a lab
i kind of like that and that's sort of
where i am for the most part on this
i kind of like it i think it is
good but it is also while
a semi-complete experience because like
if i were to compare it
to um a two-parter like say
the zygon invasion's eye gun and version
that just feels like one
story cut in half um or even
yeah i say that as if it's a bad thing
but even like two parters that i really
love like say the impossible plan the
satan pit they feel like that too
this does feel more uh more
akin to episode
and then setting up sequel to episode
but
because it immediately sets up a whole
new
problem that must be dealt with it
doesn't have the full satisfaction and
the closure in this
in this one so it does still have that
two-part feeling and as a result
even though i like this one as a thing
unto itself
how well it's ultimately going to go
down is going to depend
heavily on what the next episode is like
and the next episode is live the land
which
well tune in next week to get my more
detailed thoughts on that
my memory of it is
huh so
uh tune in next week and check that out
in the meantime i have a patreon
it's what pays the bills and keeps the
lights on and
allows me to eat any amount you're able
to contribute is appreciated you do get
perks such as access to
uh patreon exclusive discord
early access to videos uh the ability to
see my docket in advance
to see what i have coming up and also to
vote on
potential uh subjects on occasion as
well
even if you're not able to support me on
there
all the usual stuff the liking
the sharing the subscribing all of that
helps as well
but don't feel too much pressure to do
any of it
because at the end of the day you're the
council
i'm only running the meetings and until
next time this council
is adjourned with your consent
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]